I'm Nick Jonas and this is my wired
autocomplete interview people ask me all
the time if I Google myself and the
answer is sometimes what does Nick Jonas
sing a few things jealous change levels
close find you among many musical
theater songs in the shower by myself
what does Nick Jonas do now I don't know
it's a good question what does Nick
Jones drive a 1960 Thunderbird red
convertible what does Nick Jonas look
like now um he looks like this right
here what does Nick Jonas bacon song
mean it's a valid question
it's about life being so good that you
might as well throw some bacon on it
just make it that much better
his Nick Jonas wedding bells about Miley
is that the really the first one that's
so funny yeah it was so yeah that's
there you go his Nick Jonas vegan
definitely not I would have already told
you if I was his Nick Jonas English no
this is so odd to know that these are
the things that people is Nick Jonas a
fighter no I've never been in a real
fight before actually just fake ones is
Nick Jonas coming to Guam I hope so I'm
glad to know what they want me to go
where Nick Jonas parents from Newburgh
New York and North Carolina where did
Nick Jonas get his start in a hair salon
the mom was getting her hair done and I
was about six years old I was just
singing while she was getting her down
and someone heard it and suggested that
I go see this manager I wouldn't saw the
manager and they started sending me on
auditions for Broadway shows and that's
kind of how it all began where does Nick
Jonas hang out oh I skipped one sorry
well I need to tell you that I hang out
at my house good restaurants keep it
chill hanging with friends where is Nick
Jonas filming in Cincinnati huh another
interesting surprising one we were
filming all over the place this
beautiful place
I like Ohio a lot does Nick Jonas play
drums yes I do is my first instrument
actually does Nick Jonas have a sister
no I have a sister-in-law does Nick
Jonas wrote his own music
I have wrote in a lot of my own music
doesn't Nick Jonas have a star on the
Walk of Fame no it's a great question
now I like what your minds that what
does Nick Jonas tattoo say I've got a
few this one says mercy
this one says God is greater than the
highs and lows this one's an arrow my
brother not have arrows that point at
each other so let me stand back-to-back
got Joe's backs
how did Nick Jonas become famous it's a
combination of hard work dedication and
right place right time and a lot of luck
did Nick Jonas go to college no but I
visited the campus of Northwestern
actually the real dream was just to be
able to walk on the baseball team and
see if I could do it
if that didn't happen I would probably
just quit done other things I think
Jonas right below what does he cool what
is that no one knows well then yes of
course I wrote it
how does Nick Jonas die on scream queens
good question I'm still not quite sure
myself bit confusing but I did die and I
was at one point the Red Devil so what
is Nick Jonas net worth I knew this
question won't be on her why don't you
google that one what is Nick Jonas phone
number my number is what does Nick Jonas
jealous about basically loving somebody
I think for a long time I thought it was
about jealousy but it's really not it's
about loving somebody and feeling like
you don't want to share that love with
the whole world you want to share which
is that one person what does Nick Jonas
eat Nick Jonas eats eggs in the morning
for breakfast a lunch we're gonna go
with some kind of salad mid-afternoon
snack I'm gonna go with an apple I'm
into apples these days really feeling it
dinner's gonna be chicken maybe some
fish or perhaps some red meat
it could always go for a steak and a
glass or two of wine possibly more does
Nick Jonas have a baby it's probably
Google that actually kidding I don't
have a baby